a shiny new Dragon Gets serenaded In the
final episode of season one of House of
the Dragon but which Dragon was that and
where did it come from spoilers ahead
the finale of House of the Dragon season
1 is finally here bringing with it the
true beginning of the Targaryen civil
war known as the dance of the Dragons
prior to the episode's jaw-dropping
climax Damon Targaryen and the rest of
the blacks loyal to Queen rhaenyra
Targaryen devised a strategy for their
inevitable conflict with the greens a
faction led by Queen Alison Hightower
and King aegon II during these battle
preparations much is made of the fact
that the blacks have a far greater
number of dragons than the greens
special typically they currently own
seven dragons to the greens four though
one of those four is Veigar the largest
dragon in the land on top of that Damon
also asserts that there are a slew of
unclaimed dragons which can still be
claimed and bound to their cause
including the legendary Verma Thor and
Silverwing who both reside on the dragon
mount that puts the final Dragon count
at Dragonstone has 13 to their fall
I also have a score of eggs incubating
in the dragon Mound
later in the episode we actually see
Damon singing in High Valyrian to Verma
Thor in a cave though you may not have
realized it at the time since this
immense bronze dragon is only identified
through subtitles adding to the
confusion is the fact that we aren't
given information about how Verma Thor
first arrived on dragon mount nor who
his writer was before he landed there
but the show's Source material Fire and
Blood has the answers minor spoilers for
that book starting now to understand the
importance of Verma Thor nicknamed the
bronze Fury for his unmistakable bronze
hide you first have to recognize the
fact that his first writer was none
other than King jaharis Targaryen the
first who we first met back in episode 1
during a flashback to the great Council
of 101 AC wherein he named viserys as
his Heir vermouthor stayed by King
joharis's side until the King's death at
which point the dragon fled to a cavern
within the volcano known as the dragon
mount Verma Thor has since brooded there
throughout the entire reign of King
viserys and when we meet him in House of
the Dragon he's nearly 100 years old in
the books it said that only vegar and
balerion the black dread aegon the
conqueror's dragon were larger than
vermouthor making him the second largest
dragon in all of House of the dragon and
an important weapon for the blacks
should they successfully claim him for
their side despite the fact that we
don't see any other dragons during
Damon's surprising confrontation with
firmathor it's worth noting that he
shares his home on the dragon Mound with
another riderless Dragon Silverwing
originally the dragon of Queen alisan
Targaryen wife of King jaharis according
to the Fire and Blood chapter the dying
of the Dragons It's said that Silverwing
and vermouthor also made it following
their writer's deaths and although their
specific lineage is not confirmed within
the books this is significant due to
Damon's previous claim about having a
score of eggs incubating in the dragon
mount indeed on top of the potential
power that would be brought to the
blacks should they successfully claim
the mass of vermouthor it's possible
that vermouthor and Silverwing have
provided them with another clutch of
eggs to secure the future of their
faction although it's currently unclear
what role Verma Thor will play in the
next season of House of the Dragon his
expected appearance in the season finale
makes it clear that he and his potential
brood of eggs could become an important
part of the story moving forward